sur le site de la municipalité trois
dates étaient proposés aux cas sien pour
que souhaite organiser des débats le 28
janvier le 4 février et le 8 mars
trois dates proposées et un résultat qui
pose question sap a répondu pour le mois
de janvier aucune sollicitation
si la date du 28 janvier n'a pas
mobilisé les habitants de chessy celle
du 4 février n'ont plus aucune demande
aucune sollicitation n'a été enregistré
sur le site
le deuxième débat organisé est donc lui
aussi annulé une situation qui chagrine
un peu le maire d'une ville qui compte
quand même presque 9000 habitants
alors que se passe-t-il à chécy défiance
vis-à-vis du politique des intérêts ou
fatalisme sûrement un peu des trois même
si on y va et où même son écrit ça va
changer quoi rien donc non c'est ça
votre sentiment à rien changé donc c'est
pas la peine de faire des débats c'est
pas la peine
vous êtes un peu fataliste bah oui
peut-être qu'ils nous ont ressentent pas
le besoin
peut-être que deux choses le début a été
très foot est très très perturbé
chaotique on peut le dire comme ça et
puis deuxièmement il ya je crois des
questions qui sont portées par plein de
gens et que par des gens
jusqu'au boutiste sûr que vont devenir
nos expressions est ce qu'on sera
est ce qu'on sera vraiment tendu et est
ce qu'on aura sincèrement légitimement
un certain nombre de réponses aux
questions qu'on peut se poser
pas de débat organisé à chécy pour
l'instant mais des doléances tout de
même une petite cinquantaine avec en
tête des revendications le
rétablissement de l'impôt sur la fortune
ou l'annulation de la csg pour les
retraités